I think your pants is vibrated my pants
yeah there's something else cat okay
penis joke you're famous vibrates yeah
it's an amazing thing
amazing things happen with my bean had
it artificially installed you know maybe
that should just kind of standard yeah I
know I wish we were all born with this
awesome vibrating penis that I have I
think sex would be a lot better for
everybody okay we're done here hey guys
I'm Ryan and I'm Kat and tonight or
today it's daytime right now we're gonna
watch this second trailer for Noah
awesome based on the biblical story
which some of you believe is 100% true
do I believe it's true actually yeah I
do believe it's true yeah yeah yeah
Noah's Ark you know how he got two of
every animal they all got on a ship they
sail for 40 days and 40 nights and now
we have one that's correct
trust me that's the story of life is it
because I thought maybe was like Jesus
you know didn't eat for 40 days no
that's just a myth okay but yet God
flooded the earth because we were all
[ __ ] but he's like you know there's a
few people though like 10 people who are
pretty good though out of the thousands
that exist I don't know thousands
billions whatever so now we're all
related to Noah now we're all related to
Noah because his family just all had sex
with each other and now you're mm-hmm
no does he have a last name mark I think
Noah is his last name no what's his
first name is probably like John John no
John noah darren aronofsky he directed
this film he makes the most depressing
movies ever and I am excited you know
Darren Aronofsky's yeah yeah I've heard
of him before
you know Black Swan Reckling for a dream
damn you do know him you know there's my
favorite directors oh yes any names
Marin ask you another favor directors
you have to worry about a little bit you
know yeah because his films are dark and
moody and beautiful though yeah they're
beautiful they're like the most
beautiful depressing films you'll ever
see remember that scene in requiem for a
dream when Jennifer Connelly and that
one girl for life oh my god rubbing
their asses against each other with a
dildos thing I wonder if that guy got
his sag card you know the one who was
just like speaking in front of the
camera you know
I was a great scene that's a great movie
ah all right time to get depressed over
Noah Emma Watson's introducing this and
a comedy even British yes it's a fact
god I want to do her so badly I just
still think of her as Hermione like I
still think of her as a kid no matter
how old she gets
that he shot beautifully it's a lot
darker than you'd expect for a nomadic
taste of Noah
I was just picture like this little
wooden Ark toys for children and things
like that when I think of this story cuz
it's it's really something we all view
as a children's story you know ya know
now they're making this like rebooting
it yeah
screaming tents family has conflict damn
hey Winston what the [ __ ] that's Bible
are they really
you see they totally gave away that they
build the Ark and that they survived its
bastard boiler alert what if what if you
haven't read the Bible huh
or what did you read it's the same thing
the Old Testament Old Testament they
read the Old Testament very very similar
this movie's gonna be huge because
you're gonna get a questions yeah yeah
the Torah that's what it's called the
Torah they're promoting the hell out of
Emma Watson for some reason now I'm not
entirely sure why not you know I mean
yeah she's hot but I thought it was
about Noah trying to get the young
people yeah the movie they're like you
watched Harry Potter you watch this
right it's got her in it that's true
that's a good way to look at it in
Russell Crowe no one looks like a badass
in this movie man he's kind of doing his
gladiator thing about it yeah he's like
the griffon late
he's like a buff Noah yeah you just use
like a man who like works with his hands
a lot you know yeah yeah makes sense way
it has so many kids is able to satisfy
that woman those magic hands so what do
you think about when you think of when I
read the Bible that's what I was
thinking and I was like this guy's a
player man damn his wife did not want to
go and birth control back then
simple as that I didn't even know they
had it back then she have to like good
at the CVS and get it yeah yeah it was a
CVS looked a lot different back then a
lot of people would die when they went
into CVS back then just slaughter and
been slaughtering and greed it was just
an awful CVS they had a 99-cent store
extremely expensive back then during the
Great Depression that was like 99 movies
you could go to see your son yeah I
think Darren Aronofsky's stuck in the
Great Depression yeah this film does
look cool I'm sad to see Jennifer
Connelly again you know she had that
dildo scene we were talking about
earlier and now she's back working with
Darren Aronofsky doing a biblical
adaptation yeah yeah it's a great
transition in a great part to you for
them to work together and it's IMAX
IMAX rocks well I want you to watch a
movie about the ark sinking yeah yeah
what that's Titanic oh lordy you're
thinking about the wrong room sinking in
the ark I didn't know that Noah had a
villain that he had to go against Ray
Ray Winstone who's always playing bad
guys I don't think
license there maybe mmm oh yeah there's
that one moment with a sword shinning
does fire I heard there's like angels
and demons in this and Tom Hanks - yeah
yeah I'm excited to be on an island like
just sitting there with his little ball
you know that would be great yeah
universe the whole time okay guys thanks
for check out us watching a trailer yes
thank you so um why don't you do this
that's a subscribe button people captain
you know what I was doing that's a
subscribe button and click it and
suggest more trailers you know the other
day I did a trailer reaction to the
spider-man movie clips and I countered I
had 32 trailer requests as of today I
have 45 that is - seeing the two trailer
requests in another trailer so suggest
more suggest more it's it's the best
excuse to just stop doing everything
else and just watch some trailers man so
notice the trailers better than the
movie a lot of the time the trailers
better than the movie have you seen
x-men origins Wolverine I did see that
yeah it's pretty awful with that trailer
[ __ ] rocked yeah I wasn't crazy about
how they portrayed Cabot mmm damn my
favorite I used to throw cards of people
when I was a kid and I was like I'm
Candace and she got her ass kicked then
I started setting them on fire no that
would be cool oh it's a real salvation
that's another one that had an awesome
trailer but sucked but this movies gonna
rock darren aronofsky can't do wrong
even when his movies are bad they're
still considered pretty good thanks guys
you stay classy San Diego